قام الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة تسلا إيلون ماسك بالتغريد بالفعل
ردًا على اقتراح يمكن أن
تبيع تسلا عملة البيتكوين الخاصة بها وهي تحمل
أن كلمة واحدة أرسلت عملة البيتكوين والعملات المشفرة الرئيسية الأخرى التي
تغرق
المسك في وقت لاحق ، أوضح أن تسلا لم تبيع
البيتكوين باولا مونيكا معنا ، أعني أن
بول قد
مر على الفشار بصراحة تامة
في عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ،
تعلم أنه لا بأس عندما تكون واحدًا
من أغنى الرجال في العالم
للعب الألعاب بفعالية ، وأعتقد أن ذلك في
مساحة التشفير للعديد من الأشخاص الذين
يستثمرون في الكثير من
مستثمري التجزئة الذين تم جذبهم إلى
مساحة الأصول الرقمية وهناك
مستثمرو البيتكوين على وجه الخصوص ،
أشعر بالأسف تجاههم ، نعم
أتفق معك جوليا ، إنه أمر
مثير للقلق بالتأكيد أن فردًا واحدًا
لديه نفوذ كبير لدرجة أنك عندما تشير إلى
تغريدة مشفرة من كلمة واحدة ترسل
قيمة البيتكوين والعملات المشفرة الأخرى إلى الانخفاض
لأنك تعلم  بدأ الناس في
تفسير ما كان يقصده حقًا
هو خروج تسلا من عملة البيتكوين بالفعل
، ثم اضطر إلى التوضيح والقول لا
، لم نبيع
أي من مقتنياتنا أعتقد أنه في أفضل الأحوال
ما يفعله إيلون ماسك على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
هو أمر
متهور وفي أسوأ الأحوال يكون
غير مسؤول تمامًا وأنت تعلم أنه مظلل
حقًا لوضعه بشكل معتدل أعتقد
أن المستثمرين يجب أن يكونوا قلقين من أن
إيلون ماسك
قوي جدًا  وهذا يشير إلى
أنني تلقيت تقريرًا بحثيًا هذا
الصباح
أثار قلقًا مثيرًا للاهتمام
وهو أن كل شخص بما في ذلك إيلون ماسك يريد العملات المشفرة وبيتكوين
أن تكون
طريقة دفع قابلة للتطبيق وليس مجرد
ذهب رقمي لا يمكنك الحصول عليه عندما
تتقلب القيمة
20 في أي أسبوع معين لمجرد أن
فردًا واحدًا يغرد بشيء
لا يمكنك
دفعه مقابل شيء ما إذا كانت قيمة تلك
العملة ستنخفض ، ولهذا السبب
لا يزال الناس يستخدمون الدولار الأمريكي ، ومع
ذلك فهذه نقطة رائعة وهذا يعطي
النقطة التي أشرت إليها يوم
الجمعة وهي أنه يجب عليك فصل
فكرة أن هذا مخزن للثروة
وهذا يعني
الاحتفاظ بها في الميزانية العمومية
ويمكن القول إن إيلون مسك  أنه لا يزال
يفعل ذلك مقابل
استخدامه كوسيلة للتبادل ، أعني
أنه قال
وفي هذا البيان أننا وصلنا يوم الجمعة
ما زلنا نبحث في
العملات المشفرة الأخرى التي تستخدم أقل من واحد
بالمائة من طاقة
ومعاملات البيتكوين وأعتقد  هذا ما
يرجع إلى ما حدث على الأرض هنا ، هل أساء إيلون ماسك فهم
كثافة الطاقة
النسبية لعملة البيتكوين
أو كانت هذه لعبة كبيرة خاصةً
عندما يتحدث عن
استخدام عملات البيتكوين أو الأشخاص الذين يدفعون
بالدوجكوينز للذهاب إلى القمر